Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ognuno, nella vita,
fa il lavoro che gli capita.
Io, per esempio, mi occupo
di proteggere i giganti.
Facciamo un passo indietro.
So che non ci conosciamo oggi,
ma so già che abbiamo
molte cose in comune;
tra cui una, su cui
vorrei soffermarmi oggi.
Almeno una volta, nella nostra vita,
abbiamo guardato dal basso
dei giganti intorno a noi:
siamo stati tutti bambini!
E cercate di ricordarvi com'era:
io mi ricordo che mi sentivo così lontana
dal sapere quello che sapevano
gli adulti da lassù.
Ma allo stesso tempo,
"dal basso" mi sentivo
più vicino alla terra:
all'odore dell'erba,
a seguire i suoni dei grilli,
ad alzare ogni singola pietra del giardino
per scoprire chi lo abitava.
E così, ogni giorno
scoprivo decine di lombrichi, millepiedi,
porcini di terra, forbicine.
E un giorno, mi ricordo
che trovai una piccola chiocciola.
Era così piccola!
In comparazione, io ero un gigante;
ma lei, ingenua, usciva
dalla sua fragile conchiglia.
E avrei potuto spezzarla in un secondo:
ma non lo feci.
Mi insegnarono che ogni essere vivente,
piccolo o grande esso sia,
merita rispetto,
perché alla fine dei conti
viviamo tutti nello stesso posto.
Però, sapete, è facile da capire
quando siamo piccoli, vicini alla Terra,
e siamo quasi una cosa sola.
Poi, però, cresciamo
e prendiamo le distanze:
ci siamo noi e la natura,
due entità distinte.
Solo che a me non ha mai convinto,
questa divisione.
Infatti, diventando biologa
della conservazione,
che è chi si occupa di studiare,
restaurare o proteggere
gli ecosistemi e le specie
in via d'estinzione,
fu come prendere uno schiaffo in faccia.
Quando capii che quei piccoli esseri,
che tanto mi affascinavano da piccola,
come gli invertebrati,
non sono inutili ricordi d'infanzia,
ma rappresentano più del 97 percento
di tutte le specie animali nel mondo,
e stanno scomparendo
ad un ritmo allarmante
dovuto all'azione umana.
97 percento è tanto.
È come se noi, in questo teatro,
siamo circa 400 persone,
e invece che essere circa 400 esseri umani
saremmo circa 388 coleotteri,
scarafaggi, lumache, chiocciole, ragni,
api, vespe, formiche;
e forse,
metà dell'unghia di uno di voi
potrebbe rappresentarci come specie.
Anche se molte volte non li notiamo,
questi esseri sono ovunque, intorno a noi.
Si stanno muovendo in questo momento
sotto il pavimento;
alcuni, forse, sono entrati
e stanno assistendo
a questa presentazione;
altri permettono la produzione
di circa tre quarti di tutte
le colture alimentari del mondo,
come gli insetti impollinatori;
oppure permettono, aiutano
la purificazione dell'acqua,
il controllo dei parassiti delle piante,
la formazione del suolo;
in generale, tutti quei servizi
che i sistemi naturali
ci prestano, anche a noi,
e che se monetizzati equivarrebbero
a circa una fattura annua
pari al doppio dell'intero PIL mondiale,
che noi non paghiamo mai.
So che il beneficio
che le altre specie con cui
condividiamo il mondo ci possono dare
è importante, agli occhi di un adulto:
il beneficio monetario.
Ma non ci farà mai capire realmente
chi siamo, e cosa rischiamo di perdere.
È come se questa enorme
diversità di specie, e di geni,
con cui condividiamo il mondo
fosse un'alta, complessa torre genica,
in cui ognuno dei suoi pezzettini
permette di mantenere funzionanti
quei sistemi che prestano anche a noi
le risorse per sopravvivere.
E ogni qual volta tiriamo via
uno di quei pezzetti,
quella torre ha sempre meno possibilità
di poter resistere
ad eventuali perturbazioni,
come le alterazioni climatiche,
fino al suo crollo.
È come se noi decidessimo
di avere a disposizione
una microgoccia d'acqua in meno
da bere, ogni giorno.
E quando ci accorgiamo
che il bicchiere è mezzo vuoto,
è troppo tardi.
Ecco: ora pensate di essere
i bambini del nostro presente.
I vostri figli, fratelli,
sorelle, alunni, nipoti.
E sapere che nascete,
e avete già dall'inizio
meno gocce d'acqua a disposizione.
Questa meravigliosa diversità della vita,
con cui condividiamo il mondo,
non è un'interminabile dispensa.
Perché non è stata fatta per noi,
ma con noi.
E noi siamo molto più dipendenti da loro
di quanto loro lo siano da noi.
Perché, mi dispiace dirlo,
ma se noi come specie scomparissimo domani
il pianeta continuerebbe a esistere.
E fondamentalmente,
questi piccoli esserini
ci ricordano quanto siamo fragili
se, nella nostra apparente grandezza,
ci dimentichiamo, diamo per scontato
chi ci permette di vivere.
Ma, sapete, mi piace pensare
che per ognuna di queste specie
che sta scomparendo al mondo,
esiste soltanto una o più di una persona
che deve soltanto interessarsi
alla sua storia,
e cominciare a farne parte.
E per questo, oggi,
vi voglio portare
sulla linea dell'Equatore
e raccontarvi la storia
dei giganti della foresta.
E voi, ora, vi chiederete:
ma chi sono questi giganti?
Per chi ancora non l'abbia capito,
vi do alcuni indizi.
Allora: vanno più veloci di quello
che normalmente pensate;
e se li mettiamo a contatto
con la nostra mano,
cercheranno di assaggiarci
con le loro centinaia di lentine.
Cosa potranno mai essere,
queste grandi bestie pericolose?
E se fossero delle chiocciole giganti?
Sapete: le chiocciole,
nel loro quotidiano,
si svegliano e contribuiscono
al riciclo dei nutrienti,
alla formazione del suolo;
sono fonte di cibo per molti animali,
come le lucciole o come gli uccelli,
che a volte usano le loro conchiglie
come fonte di calcio per produrre le uova.
Sono anche, però, uno dei gruppi animali
con il maggior numero di estinzioni
dovute all'azione umana.
Perché, pensate,
nonostante non siano così lente,
non sono capaci di poter volare via,
o correre quando qualcuno altera
il posto dove vivono:
e quindi, quando scompaiono
è come se fosse un campanello
d'allarme per quel luogo,
che ci fa capire
che sta diventando malato,
forse in modo irreversibile.
Questa chiocciola, come altre decine
di chiocciole e lumache,
esiste soltanto in Africa Centrale,
in due isole sulla linea dell'Equatore:
le meravigliose isole
di San Tomé e Principe.
Cercate di catapultarvi là con me.
Nella foresta sentireste
sicuramente, sempre,
il costante odore di pioggia calda.
E poi, i suoni di uccelli
che esistono soltanto là:
anjoló, picanço, kitolí,
galinhola, céssia...
E poi, non solo il calore dell'ambiente:
c'è anche il calore che trasmettono
le persone che vivono là.
Queste isole, fino a pochi secoli fa,
non si sapeva nemmeno che esistessero.
Erano quasi totalmente ricoperte
da foresta vergine.
Poi, però, qualcuno le scoprì:
e come è successo
in varie parti del mondo,
non si rese conto del tesoro
in specie che esisteva là.
Cominciò ad alterarle,
con gravi squilibri
per le specie che là vivevano.
Come questa chiocciola:
che era molto abbondante,
ma poi cominciò a scomparire.
E quindi, eccoci nella foresta tropicale
a cercare di capire dove ancora
esisteva questa chiocciola.
Però capimmo subito
che non era un'avventura facile,
ma con i miei compagni
cercammo comunque di andare avanti.
E cercammo alcune aree
della foresta nativa
in cui non avevano ancora
scoperto se c'era o no.
E arrivammo sul picco
di una montagna, fino a una valle.
Fino a che ci sentimmo un po' osservati.
Ci guardiamo intorno:
erano lì, erano davanti a noi.
E invece di nascondersi,
come fanno normalmente le chiocciole,
dentro la conchiglia,
uscirono quasi totalmente
con i loro occhietti, quasi a scrutarci.
Non potete immaginare la gioia
nel vedere una specie
a cui pensavamo ansiosamente da mesi,
e finalmente era lì davanti a noi.
Io dissi: Ok, attenzione,
dobbiamo fare buona impressione
perché probabilmente è la prima volta
che vedono qualcuno della nostra specie,
un essere umano.
Perché, sapete, questa chiocciola,
così come altre specie nel mondo,
non è nata ieri:
questa specie esiste da milioni di anni.
La sua storia è molto antica.
E a volte penso, chissà cosa ha passato
durante tutto questo tempo nella foresta!
Cosa ha visto, cosa ha sentito.
E anche se nel nostro recente passato
siamo cresciute in posti
diversi del mondo,
in quel momento eravamo
una davanti all'altra.
E cominciavamo a far parte
della stessa storia.
Però, poi, quella gioia
si è un po' trasformata in paura
perché a parte me
e i miei compagni di avventura,
chi si sarebbe occupato di questa specie?
Chi si sarebbe interessato?
È solo una delle tante specie al mondo
che scompaiono senza che nessuno
nemmeno se ne accorga.
Però, poi, dalle montagne,
scendevano nelle comunità
e succedeva qualcosa di diverso.
Ogni volta che arrivavamo nelle comunità,
parlando con le persone
loro ci chiedevano:
cosa sta succedendo
alla nostra chiocciola?
E guardando gli occhi
speranzosi degli anziani,
capimmo che loro ancora si ricordavano.
La chiocciola si stava
estinguendo dalla foresta,
ma non si era estinta dalla loro memoria.
Infatti, da piccoli erano abituati
a raccoglierle dietro casa,
e non sapevano nemmeno che esistesse
solo in quelle due isole del mondo.
Quindi capimmo che eravamo ancora in tempo
per poter fare qualcosa,
tutti insieme, per questa specie,
e per il posto dove vive,
e di cui le persone sono dipendenti:
la foresta.
Poi però, guardando i bambini,
la storia era differente.
I loro occhi erano indifferenti,
perché la chiocciola
era scomparsa così rapidamente
che loro non sapevano nemmeno cosa fosse.
Senza esperienza, conoscenza o ricordi
delle condizioni ambientali passate,
le nuove generazioni non possono capire
quanto sia cambiato l'ambiente.
E quindi, generazione dopo generazione,
alla progressiva
degradazione dell'ambiente
segue una progressiva,
inconscia accettazione
del suo stato alterato.
Diminuisce sempre di più il grado
di connessione con la natura,
il legame e il ricordo con essa,
fino addirittura a poter sfociare
nella paura per le altre forme di vita,
rendendo ancora più grave
questo degrado ambientale.
Ma quello che succede
a San Tomé e Principe
non succede solo là.
Succede in ogni posto del mondo,
succede anche qua.
Non so se vi ricordate,
nelle notti d'estate,
quelle luci nell'oscurità.
Be', ci siamo accorti
che varie specie di lucciole,
in tutto il mondo, stanno scomparendo.
Se gli altri esseri viventi permettono
che noi continuiamo a esistere,
e le loro storie formano i nostri ricordi,
allora quando loro si estinguono
si estingue anche una parte di noi.
E a volte gridiamo:
Salviamo il pianeta! Salviamo la Natura!
È giusto:
ma non ci stiamo, automaticamente,
escludendo dalla questione?
Noi e la restante natura
non siamo così diversi,
non siamo così indipendenti;
siamo molto più vicini e dipendenti
di quello che pensiamo.
E se vogliamo salvare noi stessi,
dobbiamo accorgerci di chi ci sta intorno.
Perché senza natura non possiamo esistere,
se noi stessi siamo parte di lei.
Ma quindi, perché darsi
tanto da fare per una chiocciola?
Io mi rifiuto che ciò che amo scompaia.
E ciò che amo non fa parte solo di me,
ma fa parte anche di voi,
e di tutti noi che viviamo
in questo stesso posto.
E voi vi chiederete:
ok, ma cosa devo fare ora?
Sapete, il modo in cui guardiamo il mondo,
e lo mostriamo ai bambini,
e insegniamo loro le cose,
è il modo in cui loro impareranno
a osservarlo, a capirlo,
ad amarlo e infine rispettarlo.
Così come anche noi adulti, a volte,
dovremmo ricordarci di abbassarci,
come quando eravamo bambini,
e guardare il mondo
da un'altra prospettiva.
Vedere qualcuno di diverso,
e non avere timore o indifferenza.
Trasformare in curiosità,
cercare di capire la sua storia
e come il suo senso di esistere
sia anche legato al nostro.
Nelle isole di San Tomé e Principe,
le persone hanno cominciato a far parte
della storia di questa specie:
hanno imparato la grandezza
che esiste nei più piccoli,
i legami che esistono
fra le varie specie e noi,
e ha cominciato a fare qualcosa
per la sua salvaguardia.
Ma non vi sto dicendo
che per fare qualcosa dovete andare
fino sulla linea dell'Equatore.
Basta, soltanto, fermarsi.
Cercare di capire cosa è importante.
Guardare fuori dalla finestra,
in un angolo della strada.
C'è sempre un'apetta
che ha bisogno di aiuto,
una specie di coleottero
che sta scomparendo
e non lo sapevamo nemmeno.
Oppure, semplicemente,
una lumaca da osservare.
È il modo in cui noi
ci accorgiamo di loro,
e non solo del panda e della Tigre Bianca,
che ci fa capire quanto sia
fondamentale comprendere
come anche noi facciamo parte
di quella stessa, complessa
ma fragile, torre genica.
Ed è dal modo in cui trasferiamo
questo amore ai bambini,
e raccontiamo le loro storie,
che loro cresceranno
rendendosi conto
delle nostre origini comuni,
e sapendosi prendere cura
della nostra casa.
Perché, alla fine, noi siamo giganti
quando ci prendiamo cura
anche dei più piccoli.
E noi adulti, agli occhi dei bambini,
siamo sempre giganti.
Per questo, voi che tipo
di giganti volete essere?
Grazie.
(Applausi)